[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my gosh it's a Friday hello welcome
back to the break room this is our daily
can you take that louder holy crap six
shots she puts in this drink hey this is
the Breakthrough of our daily life so
that keeps you updated on all the nerdy
news you need to know live from our very
own breakthrough here at new Rockstar's
headquarters uh in Topeka Kansas coming
up on the show today King James Cameron
at it again I don't get that reference
yeah yeah oh I love his version of the
Bible uh it's the best piece of fiction
I've read in a long time uh armor Wars
using a ton of writers that wasn't a
joke that was just serious oh okay that
was oh this one's kind of using a ton of
writers this one's kind of titanius back
[ __ ] you thought she was gone you
thought you hated that character too bad
sucker she's got guns uh the series and
we deduce other people being in the
Intelligentsia other than Zach
Huddleston across the table definitely
in the Attila
so we should have put Zach on it
unconfirmed we've got a whole list of
people we think are in the intelligence
yet and we're gonna get through them uh
along with that cuddleston and Erica
Wooster
I like your naked face
oh okay speaking of naked face I don't
like the river my face is always naked
but here with a beautifully naked face
it's Jessica hey it's Friday so you know
I have my six espresso shoes
I didn't I okay so I drink these a lot
and then I was like oh it doesn't make
me too crazy and then when she said it
did make me crazy I started noticing it
does make me I can hear your heart
beating yeah I'm here I can feel it
I'm getting a migraine just watching you
drink that do you want some hey if you
drink a lot of espresso uh how about you
like this video huh yes like right now
bunny horses yeah hit the thumbs up yeah
just make sure you end on it on uh Hey
for today's Redemption I'm saying hey a
lot for today's Redemption we're taking
a trip out to the farm and visiting
pepper pots pepper patch that's right uh
for every hundred dollars we'll dive
into pepper pots pepper patch if you
know what I'm talking about for a little
spicy chicken and we have so there's a
variety of peppers here we've got we've
got some uh jalapenos some Serranos you
got a habanero the influencer thing okay
yes
we've raided them by Scoville units
there's a there's a hobby in here don't
worry yeah we'll consume them in
escalating yeah Scoville frequency so uh
a hundred dollars we will be eating the
the lower Stars will start easy I mean
we'll be building each time yeah and
that's not we won't just be eating right
that's right we're gonna test the limits
of our tongues we're gonna put our
tongues where our mouth is is uh we're
gonna say tongue twisters in honor of
pepper pops pepper patch while eating
pepper puppet pepper pots as Peppers
these were grown by Pepper pots
posthumously missing herb pontificating
partner yes
it talks a lot you know me I'm always
punching for kidding if we get to a
thousand yeah we will eat a whole candle
made no no no no no no no no no
200 we are barely making rent come on
why can't we just eat a Yankee Candle
I'm a Yankee Candle
um okay but first before we get into
that craziness we gotta do some
headlines
are you energized I I feel like burning
through my skin uh the only uh King
James recognized on this show JK I love
basketball is um James Cameron uh had a
fun headline this guy is out there doing
some wild things yeah you had a avatar
too he's like daring you to see his move
he's I dare you to come here he's
Untouchable he's like telling people on
the fox lot like I get to do whatever I
want because Titanic paid for all these
buildings it's kind of like nagging
people and it makes me want to see it I
heard on the fox light he did not use a
golf cart at all he had uh six
Executives carry him around here yeah
yeah yeah
um but he in his most recent one he
talked about
um the scripts that he had to kind of go
through again there are four Avatar
sequels in the works there's gonna be
five totals is the plan uh but he he had
this great quote he said all films work
on different levels the first is surface
which is character problem and
resolution the second is thematic what
is the movie trying to say but Avatar
also works on a third level whoa the
subconscious whoa I'm gonna fight on
myself am I being accepted during this
yeah dude he's James Cameron's in your
dreams and so he said like basically
they they had a couple scripts that
weren't good enough you had to throw
them out because they didn't reach that
third level yeah whole script ready for
the sequence like this is garbage also
how is he though well I guess it's his
grip right because I was like the judge
of what's subconscious and not
subconscious especially from just
reading it this is not even seeing the
film I will say I saw just a few clips
of it at d23 and I've been having dreams
every night that's right that's what he
meant do they have nipples what do the
nipples look like what do they do yeah
what do they do what are the nipples for
on these things
it might all be in the tail we know that
they procreate with the hair stuff well
that's part of a problem
that's how they connect to the tree I
thought into each other into each other
I'm talking about it it's working it's
back out in theaters in IMAX this
weekend we could all go see uh Avatar
and be reminded but uh again we will be
uh feverishly consuming all James
Cameron content up until the release of
Avatar Two sorry our department did a
bad job I don't know our department did
great okay in other news uh armor Wars
the uh confirmed Don Cheadle starring we
hope uh MCU series uh it's gonna be a
part of have we did it get confirmed as
part of phase five or is this a phase
six when it was coming okay they just
said it was coming yeah but it's not on
the list it was on list we all thought
it wasn't probably phase six because
there was a bunch of holes in that
schedule uh and they didn't fill them in
and like phase five most of the holes
were filmed in hey yo so
but the fact they haven't even like
begun doing anything with it I can't
imagine but but also these series can
move a lot faster than theatrical
releases right so like this could come
out by the end of 2023 we don't know but
um
I don't think that and go against Avatar
how dare you oh my god do you think
people are watching to make sure they
don't come up with things like around
Avatar's time there's not much they're
literally just letting it go to James I
mean why would you go the last one that
came out made a billion dollars why
would you go up against it that's true
yeah um but some writers have been hired
for the series so it means it is moving
forward they're hiring people to put
together some scripts uh the names
include uh Rayna McClendon who worked on
the Obi-Wan series uh lakeithia dalco
who's who's worked in horror uh Garrick
Bernard who's a comedian and has worked
on Star Trek lower decks solar opposites
and Emma flescher who uh worked on
trinkets on Netflix which is if trinkets
were a fake show name created just for
this script I would not know it wasn't
it's an actual show that came out it
only got one yeah it only got one season
yep yep oh okay they steal things yeah
let's real quick pitch a better show for
show title for a show about
kleptomaniacs oh other than drink it hot
hands hot hands I'm going to say uh five
fingers
I don't want the full time Sticky
Fingers
that apostrophe really said
if you missed that exit
hey yo
also another show another marble
property where they grab people under
Justin roiland's like hands yeah like
for solar offices that guy that guy
wrote for he's a writer for everything
and he's also a good actor and he's
funny comedian so I was like but for
writers
written right I mean it seems like right
now McClendon worked on Obi-Wan has a
ton of credits
is building a room I don't know a lot of
this information came from the wga's
website where they kind of you can
writers who are in The Guild their
information will be posted up there so
that's how it was it wasn't like a
formal announcement Marvel has not
announced this Disney is not announced
it's okay
um speaking of Marvel uh got
confirmation whoa thank you uh Brock
Humphreys in the chat we've got a bunch
of people okay it looks like it's about
to be pepper time we've had a bunch of
folks uh send us some super chats we
appreciate you we'll get to that in one
second what's the first pepper uh we're
starting off on the low end of the
Scoville units we'll be doing a banana
pepper
but we got confirmation from enuvalia
director of a bunch of the She-Hulk
episodes Titania will return okay we're
not done with her after that wedding
mishap
um she keeps annoyingly showing up to
wreck uh Jennifer's life um in fact we
we know there's still a clip from the
original trailer that we that she was in
uh Emile blonsky's weird support group
or what or Retreat that she's at we've
yet to see that take place in the show
so presumably at least that much you all
really want us to eat these hot peppers
the first two levels I have to go back
right now okay well whoever is maybe
feeling the most skittish can take
take that banana pepper and then we're
on the precipice of the second level
this will be an anime
who would like to okay Jessica's gonna
eat this pepper and then immediately say
a tongue twister oh this is so hot
to the following tongue twisters need to
be memorized by Monday
let's pick one of these
to sit and solemn silence in the dull
dark dark and a presidential person
a prison with a lifelong lock awaiting
the sensation of a short sharp shock
from a cheap and Chippy Chopper on a big
black block wow good job you did a great
job with that tongue twister
from the smell this um
bad it's good but it it's only in my
throat it's not on my tongue it's not on
my tongue at all it's only in the throat
don't make that face don't make that
noise
okay are you doing the next one all
right sure or did somebody else want to
take the next one okay Eric if you'd
like to do I think the Anaheim I believe
but it sounds like these might have been
slightly mislabeled because they
have spicy when you said I was like
banana peppers or pepper cheese yeah
there's a lot of pepper cheese okay all
right here we go Anaheim Anaheim
that one's better goodbye that's a good
oh I hope you pick that up that's what
the ASMR fans out there yes um
nothing distinctly hard to say yet
harder still to do for the
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh okay well again Chad this is not a
banana I love bananas
about my sandwich it might have just
been an albino uh jalapeno or something
okay well it's only getting worse from
here folks again the the next level is a
jalapeno a raw jalapeno uh either
Brandon and I will be forced to consume
um other other headlines uh some Oscar
buzz is already starting as we kind of
head into the home stretch of 2022 and
variety listed black panther wakanda
forever in their top 12 spots for best
picture they're kind of like weighing
all the odds
number 12.
in the first one the first one was
nominated for Best Picture obviously
um and in you know 10 movies get
nominated for best picture so top 12 is
not a guarantee that it will be
nominated but at least means there's
there's some heat around it well and
they have like Elvis in the top of this
and I don't know if the long tail of
that movie is going to get an Oscar
if your movie is over three hours they
automatically put you investment
that's true um yeah and you know some of
the movies they they had kind of as as
perspective Elvis everything everywhere
all at once top gun Maverick uh a bunch
of like smaller movies like The Banshee
of insuring and a lot of movies that
haven't even released yet kind of coming
out in the World season
um and then there's this cool interview
um filipino-based uh uh visual artist or
I'm I don't know if he's actually based
on sorry the title I gave was really
hard yeah uh visual artist Anthony
Francisco uh who's on a podcast the
mexipino podcast and he talked about he
um was one of the artists responsible
for modeling Baby Groot
um I guess was it in the I am grit
series or this is just in general
when they first had Baby Groot in the
second Garden of the Galaxy yeah um and
he mentioned a couple uh things that he
drew inspiration from one just being his
son which is really fun and he's like
every time I see baby good I see my son
in him and
um uh he he mentioned that he modeled
the bark texture on a very specific
Filipino tree the ballet ballet ballet
I'm mispronouncing it any anybody that
can speak better Spanish or uh Tagalog
or whatever in the chat uh breath feels
hot
tree texture which is really cool this
is a Sprite this will make it worse I'm
so sorry no no no problem uh we have a
clip of him talking yeah oh yeah
how else could I add more of my you know
Filipino culture in here even though
he's already a tree plant but I wanted
to use a specific type of tree called
the balita tree in the Philippines and
this story is about that right the
balita Chira the white lady like resides
I use some of the textures from that and
the way uh The Roots kind of hang down
as one of the limbs and the internal
parts of baby
okay that's so sweet it's also so cute
and I I it's it's hard it's hard getting
culturally like to put yourself in the
Forefront and try to get in there
especially even as a visual artist so I
love that even going as hard as like
making sure the tree is a Filipino tree
and making sure it resembles my son he's
as playful as Filipino children and I'm
like oh
yeah the tree here was referencing yeah
it's a wild looking tree yeah
wow looking too wild uh and then uh
other news uh a new Cloverfield film is
on the way which that is a weirdly uh
deep franchise right there's got three
of those this will be the fourth movie
uh Cloverfield Lane was the last one
right uh no Paradox oh yes yes
um and a director is announced
who's mostly done uh I believe he's a an
Iranian uh Persian uh director who's
done a lot of like foreign horror movies
which is kind of cool makes a lot of
sense for this franchise
um we've um JJ Abrams Matt Reeves and
Drew Goddard all executive producing and
I just want to take this moment to talk
about this franchise and the directors
that have come through this franchise
okay obviously JJ Abrams has been kind
of the The Godfather of this whole
project the the series is named after
the street in Santa Monica where his
office is right in Cloverfield yeah um
but the first one direct did the first
Cloverfield movie directed by Matt
Reeves of the Batman Rise of the Planet
of the Apes right ton of success the
second one
um uh 13 Cloverfield Lane was directed
by Dan Trachtenberg who just did prey oh
that's a predator movie we all liked
right and he's done a lot of like big
time TV directing in between two but
then the third movie Cloverfield Paradox
was uh directed by this guy Julius Ona
who's directing uh Captain America New
World Order yeah so it's like everybody
that has come through this franchise it
was kind of their big break and they've
gone on to do really cool things so we
got to assume the same thing for babak
on Vari we'll keep an eye out I'm sure
Kevin feige's already blown up his his
DMS
and we don't know if this is like a
sequel a prequel like where it fits in
the world they're so weird with that
franchise too because Cloverfield
Paradox it was like a surprise that it
was a Cloverfield movie not until like
the trailer came out did anyone know
what it was and they're like 10
Cloverfield Lane like obviously it was
related but no one knew how they
wouldn't tell anybody and you see the
movie like how is the season related at
the very end it is
not even have Cloverfield in the title
or do you think they have to have I
think they want to do it just so like
for future sure future reasons where
people are collecting the movies and
want to see the whole thing but they had
this whole like online campaign on
websites like all about like this uh
company that was Drilling in the ocean
and that's what released the initial
Cloverfield monster none of this is in
any of the movies and it's like all all
this lore that you have to like really
dive into to find anything the thing is
explanation of it genuinely this is
probably why I like it so much is that
I'm like yeah the you took like uh not
in the storyline a historical moment and
you can just do it from point of views
from different places all over the world
which is so fun but I to be fair I
haven't watched the Netflix one yet so
that's on me no no well and one other
thing the other executive producer and
the person who wrote at least one part
of the franchise uh Drew Goddard he
created the Netflix Daredevil series and
he's writing the Sinister Six movie
that's in the works at Sony so it's like
there's a lot of kind of connections to
Marvel and superhero films and DC films
and all that
um and then finally this is uh something
that tickles all of us you know the
break room tickle is truly a reflection
of what we talk about here in New
rockstars when we're you know just just
shooting the ass in the hallway or
whatever and this came up in company
slack there was a Twitter thread that
went viral of somebody collecting some
of our most memeiest uh
stereotypical whatever thumbnails right
and putting them together we have a few
it was a tweet the user was at warsky
kind of compiled some of our and you
know the like uh what was he cooking
um Thanos thumbnail has gone viral a
couple it's always been very popular yes
that is a very stereotypical uh big
question specifically that's the show
that that was for questions
and they're Brandon yes and Brandon came
up with some of these there was a long
and kudos to our editors Joshua John
Devin there's a lot of Riley a lot of
great editors new rockstars that put
these together
um but it became this giant thread of of
new rockstars uh thumbnails that people
were making fun of and being like Oh I
use this as a meme all the time people a
lot of people did not realize it was
from new rock stars yeah they did not
understand that we were the source of
this meme another of my favorite I don't
know if we have this one but the um the
the Joker or uh the Riddler from the
Batman wall Danna one yeah
there's um there's one which I don't
think is also on this list that I really
love the uh what are they hiding and
it's Thor
yeah
why'd you run through a few of them Dash
over here yes no that one actually that
one was my favorite that one that goes
hard this one's like metal as hell that
one is so funny oh there it is part of a
long series
um does X character F or not F or never
F or what my wallpaper is the Emperor
palette this is popular on like sports
you see a lot like they came here that's
so funny can he do it uh this was a
break room one we made it on the list we
got memed a little bit nice who will he
kill well I want to see though this is
that's not just that's not enough this
is a fake you can tell that's not new
rock stars because look at that font
that ain't nice okay that ain't us also
I will say like it's not really our
style to have the circle not be
something that's actually in the frame
this is somebody doing an impression of
a new Rockstar's thumbnail but not doing
it as well as we do shame on their
Impressions
there's the Shameless
there was an old episode of big question
with Eric and Philip Molina where they
they went through the poorest
superheroes it was messed up and so
we know for a fact one of them is uh
Falcon Sam Wilson
yeah the episode might have come out
before yeah yeah when he's getting
turned down for a bank loan poor guy
um but anyways so uh throw it throw in
the chat I think there might be a poll
going on right now uh tag us with your
favorite one or if you've got a there
was also in that same thread there was a
lot of fake ones that people have used
like did he come
[Laughter]
uh but anyways uh it's always fun when
we can cross over beyond our little
niche of the internet and find a little
meme land of our own uh speaking of
finding a little land of your own hey we
want to thank one of the sponsors of
this show aspiration we've been talking
about them all week we're very
appreciative of them check out that that
uh link is on screen right now go there
right now and sign up uh because uh the
cool thing about aspiration is it's a
debit card that helps the environment
right
um You can switch to the planet side and
get aspiration act they are climate
friendly alternative to Big Banks you
can get an account and a debit card that
is fossil fuel free they don't invest in
any kind of uh fossil fuels uh and you
can plant a tree by rounding up every
swipe of your debit card what a nice day
you get you get a seven shot
and boom you round up you know an extra
29 cents or whatever and now you're
planting a treat I'm sold uh they've
been hard at work they've planted over
100 million trees and their goal is to
plant a billion by 2030. and uh not only
is it great for the environment it's
also just a good bank there's no credit
check no overdraft fees and you just pay
what you think is fair even if that's
zero as far as like monthly payments
because money shouldn't stand in the way
of you doing the right thing for this
planet make your dollars make a
difference open an aspiration account at
aspiration.com break room debit and move
your money out of fossil fuels help save
the planet with your aspiration debit
card open that account the Link's right
on screen it's also in the description
of this video uh aspiration.com
breakroom debit today uh terms and
conditions apply thank you to aspiration
for sponsoring us all day long yes thank
you thank you thank you to all our super
Chatters out there oh we need to shout
some of them
knick-knack sent in a big super General
he's saying eat up love you all wait eat
up is that where the episodes
Mikey Mikey cheers asking can I get Ohio
Max Savage saw a trailer today for a fun
looking Bollywood superhero movie yes
yes
I think I saw this trailer but I don't
know no it's not starting gingo okay
okay I'll see it I'll see it uh Brock
Humphries with the X-Men how will they
come into the MCU I think krakowa and
the Deviant tie in oh like with the uh
where the from the Eternal for the
eternals film with kringo uh Gringo
Chris Gringo
that's my favorite with the with the The
Volcano popping off maybe that's how
they come in yeah and thank you to uh
Wolverine Brad Van Boogie's work Miss
Tony star this is Tony Stark that's Mrs
it's a married Tony
um thank you all for all the super chats
again when we hit a multiple of a
hundred somebody and and now we're
getting into the weeds
okay we're gonna be doing raw jalapenos
raw Habaneros okay A little ruin your
life
just our polls because I I I'm usually
the first one to skip them do you think
I'm going to outperform the original 55
of you guys said no this is tight that
well the thing is that it came out in
2012 something like that yeah and so it
was 2009. I remember no
I graduated high school and I remember I
did a little thing and I went to go see
it and then I remember being like this
is the greatest movie 2012. you sure you
weren't graduating Middle School no I'm
100 sure it was high are you smoking
weeded milk this is when I was a little
oh my God I outed myself do you think oh
we will see ironheart in armor Wars you
guys said yes 92 absolutely do you think
titanium is the real villain of She-Hulk
absolutely not we know who it is it's
Todd you guys now it is time to do the
discussion which is on the thumbnail I
had six shots in the most recent video
of She-Hulk were introduced to the
Intelligentsia a supervillain
organization within the MCU and my
Marvel Comics but it's not our first
introduction to them uh we see them
technically it's like a very quick
mention in Age of Ultron
it's a quick mention in Age of Ultron we
see a file that goes by that has Ulysses
uh Ulysses uh Claw from the Nissan Black
Panther and it says former
Intelligentsia so he used to work for
the intelligencia which means he's
probably posting some s post Reddit yeah
and just in case folks did not see this
in the most recent She-Hulk episode
right this is the intelligentia is the
kind of password protected or whatever
kind of private
Reddit yeah and
um so we thought about it and we were
like who else would be on the
intelligencia that we've already seen in
Marvel Cinematic Universe or some from
the comics that are coming to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so we created this
white board
here can I see the mouse really quick
yes uh and again this is
um what we have so far seen of the
Intelligentsia Nikki and Jennifer we're
kind of or no it was Nikki and Mallory
we're discovering it while Jennifer was
off at the wedding
um they are uh uh it seems to be a lot
of uh She-Hulk based uh hate right it's
a lot of what we can only assume our men
kind of like uh plotting her demise
maybe uh tracking mistakes things like
that talking trash on the internet yes
we're all standing up right yeah we kind
of have to so here's we up here Brandon
our creative our art department head my
business we're just slamming the art
Department
created uh we made a list of different
characters from the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and in the Marvel Comics that
we think if they were a part of the
intelligencia we have low probability
chance that they were medium probability
chance that they were and high
probability chance that they were so
we're gonna take turns and choose
characters that we think were definitely
maybe or were not at all a part of this
horrible toxic website okay because if
if claw was a part of an Intelligentsia
right and it might not be the same what
we have today right now it's it's this
online Forum but it could have been a
much more impressive organization back
in the day that was real
um hydra-esque you were saying hi yes
yeah yeah and like this is the modern
interpretation it's just devolved into
it's lost a lot of power and now it's
just this website or these gentlemen on
the website are trying to ape uh uh yeah
the intelligence
yeah and it's sort of like a
mandarin-esque Iron Man 3 movement
they're like we're calling ourselves
intelligent I also think it's good to
note that some people just like are
curious and probably enter so we can put
a lot of people just out of curiosity
really quick I'm just going to yell
their names we have agent Denver we have
Eleanor Bishop K Bishop's mom Phil
Coulson Dr Doom Tony Stark the new
Cassie Lang that's going to be
premiering not the other two uh we got
Tony Stark himself awesome Andy which is
Andy the Android uh that's featured in
the comic books that was created by the
Mad thinker who are both part of the
original intelligencia uh this is Val
Valentina or yeah and then we have teen
group not to be confused with Baby Groot
because you can't use the internet we
have Drake off we have uh Wilson Fisk
we're at Modoc Echo the leader uh pug
Pepper Potts and Mallory books
Ezekiel stain the sun the sun I know
this is a picture of yeah yeah guys
let's get into this real quick okay
please there's a rumor that it's a deal
stain his son might show up in like
armor Wars or iron heart might come on
this noted comic book villains and
character both of them are comic books
now if if Intelligentsia was like a real
organization right uh and Tony Stark has
admitted like he knew Claw from like
those weapons conferences and stuff like
that and let's face it Tony Stark in the
80s early 90s
and I bet him in his boss
the stains have been in intelligence
yeah definitely that's how I feel about
Phil Coulson I think he was really doing
I think Phil Coulson was doing he was
studying learning doing Espionage and I
think it's also like you don't know what
you don't know so you have to do it so I
think it's a medium closer to high that
he downloaded it just don't like to like
to catch a predator type reverse sticker
or was she mad that Maria Hill got
promoted I had a family do you think do
you think yeah there was a user in one
of those uh groups called chill fulson
or uh yeah what was his name we'll do
that as the next manager
what their names were um well I I had
the thoughts and like of again maybe
just starting with obviously characters
we haven't met at all like Dr Doom or
Modoc or whatever right like that'd be
really cool and I think like if if this
is a mandarin type situation where
there's a bunch of low-level actual
characters and then we discover that oh
there's something a much bigger
organization pulling the strings I think
we could see some of these bigger
characters but I do like we know he's
coming back oops we know uh the leader
is making an appearance in
and that's kind of you know maybe
setting up that ground level appearance
uh no no confirmation on if his head
will be it better quite at this level we
saw some weird bubbles showing up on his
forehead yeah but if he's gonna have the
3XL forehead we don't know but I I like
him I think it's high I think it's high
I agree I think I think he's much higher
I I want to move Colson down
okay fine well I think uh some secret
people we don't even think about can be
in there I think peppercussed in there
for sure high probability is in there
keeping an eye on Tony Stark well he was
in there in the 90s she was the
assistant so she probably was doing it
kept all the records I also think
Eleanor Bishop led the group
she's the head honcho oh okay she had
her hands in a lot of shady stuff Rich
lady in the Upper West Side can't trust
them okay definitely is something I
wouldn't have thought of until you you
know you guys pointed this out our dude
okay yeah now he's a good guy so far
well and I like we have Mallory and pug
on here right it's potential give me a
second because I have Mallory okay I
like the idea so far these characters
have been pretty straightforward mostly
Good Guys Mallory's got a bit of a
little bit of uh uh you know a rougher
relationship with with Jennifer
antagonistic yeah yeah it's just a
little bit of a crustier figure uh pug
is just straight up you know nice to
everybody sweetheart it's too stupid so
it does seem like but maybe one of them
is not what they seem you're going
You're Going Mallory you okay you give
your speech for why you think Pug's low
I think pug is also low I don't think I
know I'm gonna say I'm gonna say very
low for Puck only because I think on
this series
um there have not been other than Bruce
Banner a lot of uh
likable male characters now not that
that is a requirement for a show uh but
I do think like they obviously see him
in that role he is like the male friend
he is a good guy or whatever I'm gonna
say he's like very low I'm putting
Mallory High because I think Valerie I
think Mallory's husband is the leader
I've been right there
right there she talks about that she's
been in a marriage for 11 years and if
you match that up it was when he turned
into the leader not like exactly when
but it was like he's been the leadership
she is there with Nikki discovering the
Forum discovering because remember when
she was talking to Amy and Amy she
immediately cut Amy off and said that
that website for Crime man babies and
it's like yeah do you know it because
you're on it and I also just I think and
she's very dismissive and we know in the
comic she's really mean she's actually
really hostile and we haven't seen that
yet and I love this bonding that we are
getting with her but I do think her
husband is the leader and if she does
have a son I think it could be Todd but
because that's why her and Todd are
she's like he's like yeah this is my
this is my girl and I think he's like
the Stepmom but I think she's High I
think she actually knows a couple I just
want to clean up the board a little bit
some lows let me move these bless her
heart new Cassie Lang they're not
starting her off on a bad foot I know
you're you're thinking when she's
starting in prison or something like
that she's gotta I just gotta wrap she's
low she seems like a good character
to take the obvious and just put Modoc
because he's the leader of this in the
comments in the comics and the comics
but I think he also is going to be a big
part of it
he's around he's too confident for like
intelligence doesn't Kingston seem like
a not very online guy yeah
he's got his feet in the streets you
know what I mean he's not he's not a
keyboard team group
he's he's young impressionable you guys
he's so cute though he's [ __ ] posting
yeah there's a lot of cute problems
can we get does he [ __ ] yeah
does he shock does he grows go to
Euphoria High yeah I'm gonna play Drake
off as high because I think he's also
keeping an eye out on anyone that's
right
[Music]
if there is some like Mastermind and I
think like Drake off is another one here
too hey what do we know about Russians
and hacking and misinformation right wow
can you put the canceled
um but like Val right like not to say
that she necessarily believes this but
if she's out there trying to radicalize
movements against Heroes that she
doesn't like or to to somehow The
Narrative or maybe even narrative hey
get get get a radicalized movement to
take Jennifer down a couple notches then
when she's vulnerable yeah when did she
swoop in on Johnny mayonnaise uh us
agent right when he was at his lowest
battle star's dead when did she swoop in
on Yelena
so maybe she wants all these toxic men
to like come hard for Jennifer Walters
so that when she's at her lowest boom
she swoops in also wouldn't that be
great timing by Marvel they show us that
Thunderbolts lineup right we're like oh
cool you know Red Guardian Elena Bucky
everybody what if there was one face
missing from that one baby she
like using this as like a Honeypot like
she created this website just to either
track out these radical [ __ ] but
also to find some good ones too yeah
yeah you know what I mean so I could see
her I feel like I feel the strongest
about valve right I'm just gonna take
the top the comic book characters really
quick the Mad thinker is only a villain
and only that and he's like a mad
villain so he absolutely is he calling
the Mad thing is
he created Andy the Android and Andy
this Andy is in the She-Hulk comics and
is like the unpaid intern basically and
is very sweet and even if he gave him
the directive to get on this website I
think because he's so sentient now he
wouldn't do it so I'm putting him next
to pug okay and then um as a unit what
do you think Doctor Doom is I think he's
too good I think he's too good for the
interview and he's thinking he's
thinking on global planetary scale right
like he's not worried about one one
green lady you have that there that Todd
is Victor Von no no no I I said I I was
like it would be great if he was I
really highly doubt he I got a two but I
do love that I love that idea I love the
idea of more that it's Mallory I know
yeah however with Dr Doom you said this
is the intelligencia throughout all the
time so Obadiah yeah if it was a much
more powerful organization yeah maybe Dr
Drew back in the day back in the day I
think he was still he's still scientists
so I think he's very smart I think he
was like genuinely like I'm not gonna
hang out with these [ __ ] weirdos like
there are two I think he I think he does
think even before he was doomed that
he's too good for things so that's why
I'm like I I put this in the yeah
yeah nice nice toss okay we're left with
Echo Val is over here Echo again Echo
she's got other [ __ ] she's got bigger
she's busy doing kickboxing on bad guys
and stuff like that she's she's low
agent Deaver is from the dodc the one
that was um Miss Marvel
belief system
so in the chat we've had people that
were asking that aren't on this list so
like the power broker where would they
stay oh probably medium they're probably
observing what's going on to see what
people are saying and again if you view
it as a like a means to manipulate or
tick down or weaponize one like super
power being especially when it's become
very high profiles who's on the news
right she's like maybe even we don't
have like Emile Blonsky on here or
whatever other uh super powered
individuals that Jennifer might be
defending right like yeah
um would they be a part of this
perhaps I think a meal wouldn't because
he'd barely oh yeah thinking about like
Justin Hammer who's in jail but you can
still get access to the internet that's
true not a meal though not a meal was on
much more like Johnny he might be
writing in posts that someone else posts
for him like one of his seven soul mates
I get letters from prison and write
those posts on intelligencia someone
also asked Jay Jonah Jameson absolutely
on there and now that we see him as
they're definitely posting his content
he's running right right his Daily Bugle
Infowars site or whatever is is the host
he's selling tactical bathtubs
for people saying you don't think we
don't think you'll see a single one of
those people in it uh Modoc will
absolutely be a part of it we're going
to see Modoc in um Ant-Man and watch
quantumania oh also a foundational part
of new rock stars is you know what's
more fun than saying none of these
people will appear saying all of them
okay much more fun to speculate all of
them on the on the positive than on the
negative someone said ZZ Top
ZZ Top band love the three piece I want
some uh got uh was that a North
Hollywood Bar
um uh Idol hour you guys ever been there
that's my favorite there's a recording
studio right down the street actually I
was there I think for Eric voss's
birthday several years ago and
um one of the lead singer of ZZ Top was
also there could you tell because of the
beard yes he's a much smaller beard now
but he still had a beer he's very
distinctively we were talking about them
earlier today I know wow there just
needs to be one more ZZ Top and then we
all turn into ghosts
real quick uh we want to
um thank another great sponsor all week
on the break room Lands End specifically
Lands End corporate their their business
uh um attire or whatever right when you
get when you go to a trade show or a
convention and you get you know you get
a lanyard you get a tea you get a polo
you get a vest and it's got like a a
corporate Insignia on there a logo a
name something like that at the best
ones come from our friends at Land's End
okay because you know what I talked
about it yesterday you don't want sad
swag sad swag is awful right it falls
apart It's Just Junk it ends up at the
the thrift shop or or in the garbage can
even worse if you want to be promoting
your company effectively over the long
run you want these people to hold on to
these shirts these vests these lanyards
for a long time go to Land's End Lands
End Business is the best uh for
outfitting your employees and promoting
your brand uh put your logo in great
colors on t-shirts outerwear hats mugs
we did not use Lands End you have the
mandatory fun mug I'm using a mandatory
fun mug match match 143 notice that if
anybody knows the lore you know how
painful this is for me but um but you
can get a much better mug than this
dumbass mug
even it's holiday season's coming up get
all the gifts for your employees there
every business is treated like a VIP
they got great customer service see why
thousands of companies count on Lands
End Business go to business.lands
end.com slash podcast that's how they
know we sent you we get a little credit
for that and you get a good discount
because you get 25 off when you use the
promo code podcast at
business.landsend.com podcast promo code
podcast for 25 off nice thank you Lands
End that's beautiful now Brandon uh this
mug is ugly yeah okay it makes
everything taste a little bit like poo
poo it's not morbid time it does say a
phrase what is that phrase
mandatory fun
I was really low energy about it because
someone served it wow the segment the
segment's so sad we played the the title
twice for Dad oh hit the graphic why are
you why are you mailing this in so hard
uh the segment somoros that we play the
graphic three times for the toast
why do people want to watch this segment
foreign
[Applause]
this is mandatory fun the segment where
Tommy has tasked me to get together
three people that I know who are not my
best friends and to have a great time
with them regardless because everyone
could be your best friend if you dream
enough uh on today's mandatory fund
we're going to talk about how we get
some of our fandoms into the MCU uh if
you saw She-Hulk this last week you may
have noticed uh that a little dig was
thrown uh in the way of some of the
greatest pieces of literature I've ever
written the Twilight novels yeah uh what
was the specific gig well I don't know
if it's a day it was that it wasn't a
digging Patty Harrison Jacob versus his
team yeah Edward and dated both of them
yes yes that's right so Twilight exists
this would be absolutely not Twilight
exists within the MCU
it happened it's real it's there and
that's happened with other things right
the reference Superman at this point uh
Star Wars has been referencing yes
Tony's the one that calls uh Thor
Lebowski Thor whatever uh so yeah all
basically is this we were talking about
what would be like a fun way to get
something a fandom or a hobby that you
really enjoy into the MCU I've got one
yeah I really quick I know this is
Dodson in the chat that said I'm Team
Edward absolutely not go watch my
breakdown
neither of these no you're either one of
them because if you're not you're the
weird Civil War one that was on the
wrong side you haven't seen Twilight
have you no absolutely okay I absolutely
not have seen Twilight at all okay keep
going
which one of The Hunger Games was
Twilight yeah both of you I've only seen
Maze Runner and uh oh my Divergence
I'm from Washington uh
I understand that there are other movies
that take place
brought into the MCU and this might not
become a surprise to any of you if you
are you say here's the Phantom oh the
fandom oh I don't know if you want to
get
I'm just scared of eating a pepper I I
want to see it don't worry these tight
asses aren't going to crust come on
trash bags
these cowards won't let me eat a pepper
I would say if if we hit it if we hit
300 both Brandon and I will eat a
jalapeno oh yeah no problem dude and we
will do
um a tongue twister in uh stereo
uh I want to see the WWE make its way
into the MCU and to get canonized but I
want I want a hero to fight like a
wrestler you know which titanium would
be great if you don't know uh just
announced for Crown Jewel
um a show I don't agree with uh Logan
Paul is gonna fight Roman Reigns uh for
the for the champion the current
heavyweight champion well he's the
unified Champions both championships
right now the head of the table
the tribal Chief Roman Reigns so now but
now so I'd like to see like Titania in a
similar manner be like I should be as a
as a social media star I should be
challenging for a title I want her to
take on uh you know Becky Lynch or
someone from the Women's Division I
think I want to see the WWE get brought
into it yeah Bianca Bel-Air I mean
that'd be a nice man I mean Sasha Banks
were waiting for you to come back please
come oh I love you they got rid of Vince
you can come back now
please come back uh mandalorians yeah
they're all great I started watching Ria
Reya Ray Ray Ripley I love her she's
great she's so perfect she's great WWE
is a lot of fun right now folks they're
lapsed wrestling fans yeah check out
some stuff also if you subscribe to
Peacock you basically get all wrestling
for free right now aw it's great too
anyways uh this is not a wrestling show
though it could be it could be it could
be keep your Fitness crossed you and
Tommy it's just you formats
Brandon Tommy and I do have tickets for
Wrestlemania next uh
coming up in April right in fact we
might do this is way in advance so we
might do a new rockstars Meetup for
folks that are coming in oh my God
WrestleMania I won't be in the same
place
you've had your time uh other fandoms
that we went to get to the MCU this
isn't really uh like a fandom fandom I
just like you with wrestling I would
want
to see them do like I'm really into like
spooky events so I want to see them go
to like spooky events and go to like a
haunted house where they have to walk
through it and see the different Marvel
characters that are actually like good
at not being scared and the ones that do
freak out and then they punch people
Powers Yeah I mean in theory right
Marvel Zombies is coming yeah that could
be an opportunity like you know I know
it's very different it will be animated
it's not quite Canon with the live
action but like seeing like yeah what
characters freak out when they see
boogie burn zombie or whatever
how Disney or like ABC like sitcoms on
ABC they'll always find a way to do like
a Disney episode at some point like a
modern family they went to Disney World
at some point there's another show like
home economics I think the episode is
going to be at Disneyland yeah it would
be so good if like The Avengers had to
go to Avengers campus in like Disneyland
and they somehow like Aurora borrows the
situation where like they are actually
there Avengers campus is Canon
MCU why not they're public figures I
mean they've
the big difference if that were the case
the like in Canon Avengers campus would
not have like villains walking around in
costumes signing off I don't know
because Avengers con had people dressed
up as locals who as far as anyone in the
616-0 Loki is still a terrorist and they
had a Thanos
but the man who destroyed half of their
population well I I will say in their
defense I mean we were just talking
about there's yet another Jeffrey Dahmer
TV show coming out we as as
obsessed with evil Bad killing people as
they are well you don't see a Jeffrey
Dahmer ice cream shop like I bet there
is one I bet there is one there's like
oh it's coming there's like a there was
a bar called villains bar that's a lot
of bars you go into there yeah people
idolize like Al Capone and stuff like
that gangsters we love gangsters yeah
sure maybe it would be like a Hitler bar
that's not because
I think it was the pause that you gave
before you went well
Hitler bar
now I would go to like a Mussolini Cafe
[Music]
worse get a get a Peroni there and a
Negroni and Negroni and a Peroni uh with
some spumoni ice cream
um here's my mine's real quick but it
would be complicated we were talking
about this like so many actors in the
MCU are part of other franchises right
like I love Dune as a fandom I love
those books and I love the first of the
chalamet movie and I'm excited for the
next one but Zendaya is in that movie
that's true also kind of a part of MCU
Cannon would that get complicated
but Dune is like way in the future right
well no I'm not saying it's real in the
MCU I'm saying as a pop culture it's
real right it's a movie that exists it's
books that were written I thought you
wanted to make Dooney I was like yeah
let's go
no well I mean heavily these come back
they can travel through time in the MCU
that's true they still have the
technology that's right no I mean dude
if it were like real it would be more
likely to be in Star Wars I think than
an MCU but um as long as it takes place
on Tatooine I swear to God no more
tattoos I have to go back to Tatooine
Poor Man's arrakis you mean
Eric what what what what fandom would
you like to have whoa
uh I would like like to see the MCU
acknowledge and have it be in the real
MCU uh the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
I'd love to see them represent because
then we finally get the MCU to
acknowledge that there are mutants
oh and say it out loud I call them the
teenage mute or teenage enhanced Ninja
Turtles
the teenage Sonic teenage uh Turtles
um
there's a very specific kind of mutant
that we don't normally get even the
Marvel mutant tree right half animal
half human I love that
um Isaac is my favorite actor I just saw
that in Rico in the chat hell yeah dude
that guy crushes free girl pointing out
uh making new rock stars Canada in the
MCU it's pretty close
we have talked about how kind of close
it is yes because they made uh Good
Morning America canon in the MCU that's
where we first met Johnny mayonnaise and
Eric has been on Good Morning America
yes so I would say like reviews I can't
say very much
but I know for a fact there will be a
new Rockstar's Easter egg in an upcoming
superhero film uh-oh wait what tell me
please don't oh God okay yeah oh my God
what be excited there was a fan working
on a film that's snuck a new Rockstar's
logo into an upcoming film so that could
be the final confirmation of that new
rockstars exists yeah and talk about the
Aurora border Alice Eric Voss breaking
down a film that has an Eric vosh
reference in it is like we'll just break
all of our laptops
it'll cause an incursion that's my
biggest goal is just to have my
breakdown show up in just any series any
TV show anything for a second like some
kid is watching it on their phone I'd be
like amazing
yeah
we're very lucky that uh Jessica's had
some folks some kind of famous folks
reject to her about her Shield
breakdowns Eric is has frequent DMS with
some of the directors of the Game of
Thrones how's the dragon series uh we're
super lucky that folks reach out who are
fans of our work that also work in the
industry and like yeah yeah if you want
to put me on Elementary for a second
I'll be so into it yeah
come on the show yes did you see the
video of him dancing no he's uh he's
doing a lot of actual I don't know if
this is PR for Barbie but he's doing a
lot of uh just hanging out with people
on Tick Tock or just on YouTube and
there's a one team of people that are
dancers they're hip-hop dancers and he
does hip-hop videos with them and I'm
like it's because we're not dancing
in the same Lane we can get this table
out of here
yes okay
you guys don't know
uh we do wanna it is Friday uh so we do
owe them a clip of the week oh okay yeah
and not the indoor discussion and not
the apology standard we actually this is
the constantees please watch Andrew this
weekend tell your friends to watch it
it's easy just to put it as the first
discussion but we refuse absolutely I do
I really like Android it's great it's a
lot of fun really good if you've been
sitting on it like don't know three
episodes hey it's a lot it's fun hey
that's on your weekend to-do list yeah
yeah pop it on pop it on that yeah uh
but let's say you're up at our clip of
the week this week submitted to our
Discord
if you've got to spare a couple million
dollars you can start your own Clean
cleaning products company with green
chemicals that will not hurt your babies
and will not hurt your pets take it from
me Jessica Alba you can do whatever you
want
I love it I love when you go it's me
Jessica that was a perfect impression
and I know that Eric loves Jessica I
didn't even know you talked about her
earlier we had a big Jessica ZZ Top and
Jessica Alba yeah
thank you guys for letting me eat this
pepper yeah but I will throw away media
oh man we are so preciously close to hot
peppers but um we might roll that over
to next week and maybe we'll start with
the hotter peppers next week yeah and
then make Tommy do it yeah
quick shout out uh Christian
unpronounceable Jordan Gonzalez and
super chat this is me Aryan verg saying
team Alice okay
you guys are making me so mad I'm gonna
force you to watch it and it's harder to
watch now in 2022 because you're like it
looks bad it like the entire screen is
purple Jessica it looks bad back then no
we do oh my God you want to fight me
okay
um I blame the state of Washington for
producers clearly all people that come
from that state are have lower
resolution than people that come from
other states look here everything is
dark there except the sparkly vampires
yes okay so you know I I know enough to
make fun of it
um but we'll be back next week the wild
volume of good content we're getting
continues next week more House of the
Dragon more rings of power more She-Hulk
more and or more Rick and Morty
breakdowns of all of that yeah Jessica's
breakdown of this week's episode will be
on the channel it should be right now
we'll be up right now watch that watch
out your trash bags yeah yeah check that
out join our Discord or you can send me
eclipse of the week from the show we
could chat you can send in voicemails
yeah hit like and stuff like And
subscribe the only way uh we can get
Tommy back on the show is if we get
enough subscribers
we're gonna keep them under the table
in a cage somewhere else in the office
right now and only 1 000 likes on this
video
uh but uh everybody have a great weekend
uh we hope it's it's fun and happy and
uh full of good times and we'll see you
here next week let us get us